[Music]
uh we're supposed to lecture about
recent events so I guess the singfield
cup so I put in four of my favorite
games that were less than 40 moves so
then we could actually get to all of
them the next major event on the chess
calendar is in bbow Spain and it's the
European team Cup Championship plus tax
and probably of the top 100 players in
the world 85 of them will be there so
it's pretty strong so for example I
asked Fabiano who was playing on his
team and he said him hakaru an mvl so
that's a good team um and he said yeah
we'll be one of the top few teams then
some other team had had some stronger
players so yeah tough a tough crowd
anyway it starts at a couple days is all
the players flew to bbow for this event
so that'll be pretty interesting okay I
just made a video um for a website that
I won't discuss here uh on this game um
titled exciting draws this was the most
exciting draw of the singfield cup and
it was round
one sort of like I thought the most
interesting game from the US Women's
Championship was in round one when
ashria won this you know 500 hour game
and she won the prize okay so this is
the
game uh mvl versus Magnus and he
surprised Everybody by playing
scotch and in this position while Bishop
B3 is a move Bishop E3 is a move and
Knight takes C6 is a move Knight B3 is
the old move what's funny is this move
Queen E2 which wasn't very popular was
played a few years ago by Magnus and he
beat etsm bakro mv's teammate and
Countryman and such right Nick
yeah so the fact that mvl plays it
against bnus is pretty funny now here
Carlson played you know said Excuse me
while I whip this out and played A5 and
nobody plays A5 everybody castles now of
course you know hakaru said his usual
nonsense that only I know this move and
Kasparov knows this move okay but
actually aronia knew the move cuz he was
talking about it and there was a game
play in the Ukrainian championship
between yov and Von so everybody knows
this move however out of 125 games in my
database that was the only time it was
played so you would expect mvl would
be very knowledgeable about castles
because that's the main move and maybe
he would know nothing about A5 when in
fact nothing was further from the truth
mvl really knew A5 which doesn't make
any sense because it's only been played
once okay now the point of A5 is to play
A4 true story so in the volon game white
played A4 and then black didn't play A4
because that would be illegal and mvl
played the most testing move E5 now A4
is risky due to its losing because e
takes F6 check so black castled and mvl
played very quickly takes A4 now Knight
A5 Knight C5 and Knight D4 all lose the
Knight Knight D2 blocks the bishop so
Rook E8 is stronger and you would think
this is deep preparation by Carlson and
white doesn't know what he's doing when
it was almost the reverse uh mvl played
instantly every move so he had analyzed
A5 and came up with his own
ideas okay and this is all the computer
recommended
moves and this
position Carlson FL for 30 minutes and
mag uh mvl had much more time than he
started with he banged out Bishop C4
instantly he prepared this line now here
the computer gives two moves now again I
had a talk with some of my my homies
from Brugge and they were telling me
maybe mvl wasn't using the latest
version of stockfish when he prepared
this line because I have the latest
version of stockfish who doesn't and it
recommends the move that Carlson played
after 30 minutes of thought mvl didn't
know this move at all and said it wasn't
on his computer so I don't know if he
uses commod or maybe he forgot so the
two moves the computer gives are Bishop
D4 which is I think playable and the
move that Magnus eventually played which
was Knight B4
and we were shocked at Knight B4 because
Magnus obviously wasn't familiar since
he thought 30 minutes although he then
said he was familiar but he was trying
to remember if it was night B4 here or
later well Knight B4 has a lot of
threats and now mvl thought for for 25
minutes and took the Knight and black
played the obvious move Julian
D5 attacking the queen on
G4 and took back his piece now Queen H6
threatens mate which would work against
most of the players in this room however
not against Magnus who would play Queen
takes F6 stopping
mate so he
castled now if it was white to move
which it's not white would win with what
move you Rook either to D1 threatening
the queen and the queen does not have a
plethora of
squares so Magnus played B takes C2
making Rook D1 look a bit
silly okay and now black has triple
pawns which as a friend of mine once
that are three times as good okay also
they're pretty good here okay and he
played Knight D5 obviously the Knight is
taboo because Queen H6 and queen G7 M
now in the video that that I made
earlier after this game was played I
said Rook E6 exclam and it is exclam and
I said the idea of which is after Queen
H6 we play Rook takes F6 then someone
put a comment to my video and said Rook
takes F6 Bishop G5 looks pretty good for
white and I was like yep however the
point was after Queen H6 black will play
Queen f8 right okay so now m thought a
while and decided to take all of his
opponent's pawns seems like a good idea
so he took on
C4 and then excellent move was played
here by black probably only one or two
of you remember what he did yes he
played B5 the best move now Queen takes
B5 runs into a lot of stuff such as C6
or Bishop A6 so he didn't do
that Bishop B7 and this always reminds
me of one game although it should remind
me of hundreds of games but I can't
remember that much um this reminds me of
the last game in the match between topav
and Anand they were tied Anand was black
and he woned a Tarter cower with this
beautiful Bishop on B7 so whenever I see
that Bishop on B7 I really like it okay
Knight E7 check now black has a force
draw which Magnus saw and he decided to
play for a win which turned out to be a
good decision black can play Rook
takes and
then uh Queen to D2 threatening main on
G2 and
perpetual and the computer says that's
fine play that been nice game but Magnus
played for the win that surprised me not
because Magnus hasn't play for the win
Magnus is way behind on the clock and
since the position's equal anyway maybe
that's not a smart decision but maybe it
is okay so Queen takes C2 and white is a
pawn ahead although White's Knight is
sort of Trapped the bishop on B7 is good
E3 is weak Etc so good compensation for
black Rook A6 attacking the pawn on F6
and now Maxim played I think the only
mistake whoa the only mistake in the
game for his side uh computer says after
Rook to D1 the position is equal Maxim
thought a long time and played Rook to
C1 and he actually thought the upcoming
Rook sack which happened was winning for
him um although that shouldn't have
happened so the upcoming Rook sack
happened after Queen D2 threatening M
here Magnus thought until he had about
three minutes left and he made a mistake
probably his only mistake of the game
Queen D3 is the best move the the idea
is white cannot sacrifice a rook as he
did in the game because the queen on D3
is defending everything so now we have
to worry about Queen takes E3 check and
if uh White goes into the ending that
starts with queen C3 and they trade
Queens even though white is a pawn ahead
he's much worse Black plays Rook D6 Rook
D2 and computer says Black's ahead about
s so he may have one he may have drawn
we'll never know unless there's an
alternate universe you can go to uh
instead you played Queen
D2 which is an instant draw and you'll
see why in a few moves check check check
check and Magnus actually said when he
played Queen D2 he either overlooked or
underestimated this Rook sacrifice of
course in this position if there was a
black queen on D3 this Rook sacrifice
just wins for black because he can play
F5 in this position and the Queen's on
D3 so the game's over
you Queen
D3 Queen E5
exclam uh we actually looked at this
yeah that's right King G7 we looked at
this
very slowly said I like
that yeah Knight GA would allow tricks
which are for
kids yeah I think after King G7 you're
actually
Lost Queen F1 mate with advantage that
is pretty
yeah now this was we we looked at this
yeah computer said no good yeah the
knights
dominated and anyway Magnus had very
little time on his clock so would have
been risky anyway now this is funny
Magnus thought he was winning didn't see
the Rook sack mvl saw The Rook sack and
thought it was winning but they're both
wrong that's the best players in the
world we got okay and now everything is
Perpetual every legal move for both
sides leaves a Perpetual it's not like
oh no Perpetual you lose like it's all
it's all Perpetual yeah yeah here black
every move is Perpetual
here and here white thought a long time
but Queen F5 is also Perpetual
everything's Perpetual doesn't matter
every move was all zeros and then they
repeated making it easy for the crowd
yeah so both sides thought they were
winning so a draw was a fair result but
that was great play from both sides
especially Magnus who was faced with
something he didn't know and basically
played perfect and missed Queen D3 with
winning chances so but but pretty good
so my next favorite game was the game
Magnus lost to Fabiano in round two
three four who knows it was so long
ago yeah there we go yeah okay Bishop's
opening very suspicious but okay yeah C6
is one of the main
lines and Bishop B4 check is a little
Nuance you want white to play C3 so he
can't play Knight C3 which would be
illegal and that's what happened so now
White's not going to play Knight C3 but
okay white gains a Tempo problem is if
white plays Knight C3 he's putting
pressure on
D5 so now he's not going to do that okay
but this is about equal in fact this is
really equal and it was so equal that
Magnus knowing that Fabiano had a good
start 2 and0 he wanted it to not be
equal and get some action going so he
played very um um enterprising that's
the right word
yeah and in this position he played a
move move that you know very few players
would consider he played H3 put it in h
and Fabiano's like all right two Bishops
in a better Pawn structure although
black has to be careful because white
has threats threats that Fabiano did not
believe existed correctly so he played
Knight C5 and okay if white doesn't do
anything and play something boring like
Bishop to
C2 I mean he's just worse Black has two
Bishops
Bishop F7 though although very tricky
doesn't work and I think if I had the
white pieces and somehow I had this
position I would also Play Bishop F7
because after Bishop C2 I know I'm worse
um after Bishop F7 I'm confused confused
seems better than worse I have a
question question so after King
takes y so in the game he played T5
check afterwards but I think that
Knight G5 is stronger and why do you
think that because the bishop is too
strong on the
diagonal I I
agree that I thought that that helped
black yeah I agree I think it's they're
both bad for white but I think taking on
E5 does strengthen the bishop on
C7 so I can't disagree with you that was
a great question yeah yeah wasn't really
a question he was like this is better he
was like agus is terrible why don't you
play my move questions yeah I was yeah I
think I think both moves are good for
black but yeah maybe your move is
better Queen G5 is the
best and Bishop G4 I think also is the
best or one of the best now the players
always get funny comments after the game
before they've had a chance to talk to
the computer or their coaches about the
game and what Magnus said about this
game was quite funny these moves are all
reasonable he said oh 93 that's genius
and I didn't see it well he didn't see
it and it is genius but it's not
necessarily the best move but it worked
out pretty well because Magnus didn't
expect it other moves also give black
the advantage possibly a bigger
Advantage but Knight D3 plays for
mate um black has lots of pieces
attacking White's King and with a knight
on D 3 added it makes it more dangerous
for white so if white plays for example
Rook takes Rook Queen E3 check and queen
takes G3 and Knight F2 check is all
winning for black so he took the
Knight
and this
position is is obviously terrible now
here I mean material is equal but okay
white has two isolated Pawns White's
King is terrible so here white didn't
put up the best resistance and in my
opinion this wasn't magnus's best
tournament not just score-wise but a lot
of the games he really didn't play like
himself when he was losing he'd lose
without a fight when he was much better
he would draw without trying to win I
mean he tried to win he just couldn't so
there were a lot of instances in this
event where bnus didn't play like
himself if you were here last year and
you were he just played much better this
was one of those such games here White's
much worse but you would expect Magnus
to just play perfectly and draw somehow
instead of lose instantly okay
so it wasn't the Magnus we used to E6
not a good
move Queen G4 is a great
move and it's funny after Queen D6
Fabiano actually say started to get
nervous until he saw the queen H5 to e
idea then he realized that this was
probably
winning check
here yeah and um yeah after Queen H5
Magnus said I knew Knight H2 lost and
then I looked at Queen H2 and I'm like
that's terrible let's play something
else ah Knight H2 okay uh Ken West is
rolling over in his car or something you
know he's probably because it's raining
outside
yeah uh yeah this is this is this is a
Ken West story if I've ever heard one
Ken West grandm here at the chess club
if if you threaten a mate for example he
will stop it then his next move will
allow it because he already stopped it
so you know why should I keep stopping
it I've heard this story from Ken many
times this is a very similar story I
know Knight H2 is bad let's play Queen
H2 n Queen H2 is bad let's play ah
Knight H2 okay he just like forgot now
Queen H2 is terrible I admit I mean the
position's terrible because after Queen
E8 and black will round up this
Pawn you know this position is terrible
black is threatening Rook H5 with
advantage and when I say with Advantage
I ain't kidding and so if you stop Rook
H5 with the move G4 which I believe the
computer says is forced Queen takes E7
that's not good he's going to lose
anyway so he didn't like that so he
played a move that lost instantly Knight
H2 and this reminded me of something
that nobody pointed out but I'll point
it out now because you're taping me in
the match Carlson and and Anand from
last year there was a game where Carlson
was making a queen and Anand was mating
him and then Carlson made a queen and
there was some position where black I'm
sorry white which was a nond had two
pieces that could go to the same square
and he play play the one that lost
instantly that reminded me of
this bishop F1 and Knight F1 he made the
wrong one right then he resigned this
reminded me of that because this was
Queen H2 or Knight H2 man was Knight H2
bad okay if you thought you were bad
Knight H2 now after now what's funny is
Carlson thought he was winning when he
played Knight H2 because he forgot about
Rook D1 in which case White's winning
because if you play the obvious Rook e
five which looks like it wins for black
he saw
G4 and now the queen has to defend E8
and E5 a difficult
task so he was like oh I'm winning I'm
the best then after Rook G1 he said man
I'm the worst okay now yeah now you lose
everything yeah okay and he resigned
because you lose all your pieces so that
was a very UNM Magnus likee performance
frankly terrible okay but Carana played
pretty well especially with black and
facing FG Bishop takes F7 check probably
the fans were rooting for white they
want Bishop F7 to work okay
but don't work yeah hate when that
happens so I like that game quite a
bit this game I like because mvl was
white he won a game okay amazing now
this game was very strange from Leon's
point of view because he did something
that we were sure he would not do
and it was in this
position okay this position's occurred
many times in fact it occurred in a
world championship match between Banick
and Tall binck played Knight
A6 I thought I was bad and Tall you know
tore him up because that's terrible okay
if you thought bavinck was
bad takes now after the game mvl who
also plays this way with black he plays
grinfeld type positions he said well
here I just play Knight E4 and Bishop F5
and Knight bd7 and it's equal so he
thinks black is fine here and here after
you take white plays the obvious Knight
G5 which is played often in these
positions and this position Ali
Alejandro my co-host said there's no way
he'll play C takes B3 and and totally
destroy his position so of course after
thinking a long time he played C EGS B3
fact what's funny was Alejandra had to
go give an interview outside with Fox
Sports and he left in this position and
he said anybody who takes on B3 should
have their Grandmaster title taken away
then when he came back he takes B3 had
been played okay yeah and and this is
just terrible and uh again the players
always say strange things after the game
oran's like oh I didn't see Queen E3
what a strong move okay Queen E3 is a
good move computer also likes Queen B4
quite a bit with the same kind of idea
attacking every Pawn okay so white has
two Bishops and black has many many many
weak pawns and white has a better Center
okay so Queen
E3 white wants to play Queen takes E6
check and queen takes B3 and a takes
B3 okay so he takes
again and queen takes A2 so black has a
pawn ahead but black has the worst
position I ever okay terrible and he he
played badly to boots so the problem
is often D5 is coming especially when
White's Rook is on D1 and black doesn't
have any active play White can move
forward white can put tremendous
pressure on the B7 pawn and it can't
really move because then C6 is weak so
it's just just not a good position The
Rook on A8 can't move cuz the a Pawn's
hanging so a l long terms very bad he
played Rook F5 not a good
move you incorrect yeah
probably well by doing no analysis I
would say Rook a
D1 that's
illegal yeah legal moves only yeah your
Bishop's pinned
twice and three times on Saturday four
times on Sunday okay so maybe he didn't
play the best moves but they were legal
so you got to give him some credit
unlike Randy singfield okay so Rook
F5 Rook fb1 reminded me of a nice game
that I beat Jennifer shahadi a long time
ago where my Rooks were also on A1 and
B1 Queen B6 which I thought was just a
terrible move putting the queen on Queen
on the worst possible Square now a lot
of times these top players play Bad
moves not because like they look bad
they have no understanding it's because
they calculated really far ahead but
they missed something and if their
calculation was correct then their moves
great so without calculating that looks
terrible but aonian said thought here
here here here here but he was wrong not
a good tournament sorry
D D5 is actually a very strong move
sacrificing the F Pawn but he played E4
which is also
winning and Bishop C3 and the queen has
to go back
terrible yeah Queen
B2 okay and this is like a morphe game
because Black's not you know getting out
his Queen side it's like morphy's white
and his opponents like Queen B6 to C7
Rook F5 to f8 and all the players of
today make fun of morphy's opponents but
look how they play same way okay
B6 D E5 is good D5 is good everything's
good and
E5
terrible and there was a really funny
variation I wish I could remember it
where yeah I think it's I think it's
Knight D7 D6 takes Bishop D5
check yeah I think that was it Knight D7
exclam D6 Bishop
D5 and then White's
better CU White's really better man it's
better than better okay so he didn't do
that he played A5 which is
terrible yeah and okay black you know
it's just losing material I was shocked
that black didn't resign until he did
because man you get beat it's
embarrassing okay and he just played on
I guess you know so the game would last
a little longer but okay I mean black
can't do anything and there was a nice
variation here actually but it didn't
happen
yeah right and
now um if you play King H6 I think he
resigned here yeah King H6 the only
legal
move and
okay no stal
Matrix so I thought that was quite a
nice game because white just sort of did
this and usually you don't do that
against the players like that in this
tournament not like
that yeah okay and the last game in the
lecture Carana
topov this was one of my three favorite
games and the
the the preparation is very strange to
me so if I prepare let's say I'm playing
Julian and I know what he's going to do
and I prepare and then that night it
happens and I play it okay that'd be
good but if I prepare for Julian let's
say a king's Indian and then he does
something else and then I play Julian a
year later I don't remember what I
prepared okay don't you remember that I
played him a year ago and what's funny
about this game is top off played a line
he does not play and Fabiano was just
playing those moves fast and play and
Toof played a novelty and his opponent
Carana instam moved and I was like what
and he said oh yeah that's the first
line given by stockfish you though it's
a novelty so I looked at it when did you
look at it last year when I was playing
Sidler and I'm like what you remember
that okay so he prepared this for Sidler
Sidler didn't do this but he remembered
their analysis even though it wasn't
Theory so that'll teach chopov so they
played a like OV con Sicilian don't ask
me
A6 guess a what queen C I guess they're
both the time off the knights on C6 they
ult transpose okay and well top love
never plays this so I don't think caran
is ready for this but Sidler does play
this and he's played
fidler and this has all been played
before and King f8 okay black can also
play G6 in fact G6 has played more
often Knight A4 to play C four and queen
A5 Queen a5's never been played before
novelty by
topov and not only did Carana move
instantly the the move is not given by
stockfish yeah and he's like oh no we
analyze a lot of moves this is the move
we thought was the best okay so he
played Rook E2 because the Rooks
attacked good good idea and now the
queen on A5 is a little iffy unless you
trade Queens which is computer
recommended but Carana laughed and said
ridiculous much better for white
computer's stupid so he was he was all
ready for that so H5 G5 and the knight's
hanging on A4 if you move your queen to
some Square where it's not defending the
Knight so Bishop to D2 and top went into
a big thing and this is still the
pregame preparation of Carana from a
year ago against Fiddler and he was like
yeah computer says PA takes Queen bit
takes Queen is equal but that's terrible
for black and then he showed he showed
us why it was terrible and computers
wrong so that's good prep you play a
novelty and your opponents looked at it
and refuted the computer moves man it's
and after Rook e to topa thought forever
so he played novelty and didn't know
rookie too so incredible
preparation and the way the game went I
don't understand why you wouldn't trade
Queens with black because with the
Queens on the board Black's King is very
suspicious so he should just trade
queens and go into the equal end game
that Carana doesn't think is
equal okay so Queen C7 and now our Queen
can move away from our Knight on A4
because our Knight on A4 is no longer
attacked H4 which I don't think is a
good
move Rook G which I also don't think is
a good move and here basically black
can't do anything uh E5 is protected
and King is on f8 now if we go back a
move black can also play Knight takes
E5 Rook takes E5 Bishop
C3 which at first looks resign because
you're losing your Rook on F on h8 but
actually the computer goes further if I
remember this was a week ago and I can't
remember car remembers a year ago and
then F6 yeah and the computer likes
white but maybe
well okay I don't think the super jams
would agree with me but maybe this is
better than what he did you young
man they had this ACR the
street well winning and completely
winning are two different things that
would be maybe winning but completely
winning now you're now you're talking
crazy okay so instead he
played Rook G8 defend G G5 now Knight E5
is possible although not
now and this is actually quite funny in
this position when I was doing analysis
with uh all Alejandro I didn't want to
say his name but I guess I have to why
played Rook E3 preventing Knight C6 and
my commentary at the time was black will
play Knight C6 and then later in the
press conference that he overlooked Rook
F6 and Alejandra is like well Rook E3
stops Knight C6 so he won't play it and
then of course he played Knight C6 so
the one time I was right black should
play some crazy move like King
G7 and then you know put his King on the
king side where it's
safe yeah but okay black position is
terrible worst Pawn instructure King
isn't good Bishop on E7 can't move and
his opponent's about to win seven in a
row
how do you deal with all that
play well he just came from D7 so that
would be an admission of failure Knight
C6 though that way the KN goes to D4
you're all set of course in this
position if you play the obvious you
know King to
G7 then Rook F6 is
winning and I think you could play Queen
E6 and then Rook F6 might be more
winning and the idea is is then Rook
F6 also
good and there's some I think the queen
on G4 is better because with the queen
on
G4 there's some positions where you play
Knight takes a knight E6 check so you
don't want to put the queen there right
away and and White's threatening Queen
G5 which is M and Knight takes C5 and
Knight takes E6 and okay white White's
killing it
so yeah Rook E3 basically prevents
Knight C6 which was played anyway okay
so he played King E8 which is the best I
guess yeah now this isn't so good and as
I said my favorite Sopranos line don't
sue me uh there's good and there's not
good this is not good yeah black is a
piece up but it's the worst position
ever he can't do anything if he plays
Queen D7 for example to trade Queens
Queen F7 is mate The Rook on G8 is
threatened fact I think the computer
said the best move is to let white play
Queen takes Rook check and then King
D7 okay but no human's going to do that
though it's losing he saved his rook and
now Queen H6 which is by far the best
move not only does it attack The Rook It
prepares to play the move E6 which inmes
the black king on E8 and then made as
soon to follow so he gave up his Rook E6
which actually is the best to move but
all moves
win and now whites down a lot of
material but White's threatening Queen
H5 check White's threatening Queen takes
Rook White's threatening Bishop takes
rook and White's threatening Queen h8
check and basically can't stop any of
them so topof played Bishop f8 because
of the famous
rule always play Bishop
f8 Queen H5
check Bishop takes
rook and here the material is actually
in White's
favor and Bishop takes G7 loses for a
variety of reasons the best of which is
check and
E7 and if there was a referee hey there
was Chris bird the fight would be
stopped white is threatening Queen E6
mate Rook E6 check E8 equals Knight E8
equals Queen Pawn takes Rook equals
anything and King G2
solid yeah Okay g solid yeah so after
mission takes G7 black resign it's funny
like when you guys play like H5 G5 H4
they didn't get made you're like ah
would I do that but even topov does it
pushes all the Pawns in the king's side
and his King's open who would have
thought that and topov had the the
chance to trade Queens after pushing all
the Pawns in front of his King and he
didn't strange decision to me because
his King was was was not good well
sometimes when you push all your pawns
you get a big attack but sometimes you
just open your king which is what topov
did in a couple games on the other hand
topov won some games too okay unlike
certain other people who we won't
mention but so playing like for a draw
every game or boring or not exciting you
still might not win any games and if you
push all your Pawns in front of your
king and you lose you look terrible but
if you win like in the game mvl
versus
ding
Lin what was the game where he pushed
all his pawns every move I think that
was ding Lin you know from a couple
years ago the every move was a pawn push
didn't move his pieces out yeah yeah it
looks good when that works when it
doesn't work then you're like man you
don't have any pawns F here King what
are you doing so double edged of course
that's the kind of game topoff likes
probably not to caran is liking so much
I think he likes to just outplay you
slowly but okay if you're going to get
mated he'll meet you and that's why I
think car wanted is a good player he has
a style but when he plays against his
style by sacrificing or running with the
kings around like you saw with Carlson
where his King was running around and
Carlson was trying to M him and then
Carlson got mated I mean he can still
play those positions well so it's good
to have a style but it's also good to
play all positions well those were four
of my favorite games that were
relatively short uh probably my favorite
game from the event overall was the game
caruana beat aonian uh when Carana was
white he just sort of outplayed him and
beat him it wasn't like opening prep and
he was winning right away uh this game
was a lot of it was opening prep but
even after the opening prep it was
complicated he just outplayed his
opponent and I think Fabiano has sort of
a mix of good prep and then good play
afterwards uh by far the best opening
prep of the tournament but probably also
the fewest mistakes and I think he could
have scored more points he could have
got nine or n and and a half but aultry
8 and a half out of 10 frankly
depressing um and okay Carlson didn't
have his best tournament probably if he
had a good tournament he'd score plus
three or four so he'd still lose by two
points I mean he didn't lose that many
rating points either now other players
top had a normal tournament came in
third he played sort of up and down like
this game and I'm sure hakaru and Lon
want to forget their tournament and this
was mv's first tournament where the
average rating was over 2750 in fact it
was over 2,800 so he got minus two he
basically I I had these funny
discussions with fed Master V fredman I
said if you told me before the
tournament mvl gets two draws against
Carlson and beat Aon in one and a half
half probably' be pretty happy about it
maybe he was but minus two is his
overall score um basically getting
crushed both games by Carana and then
splitting with the rest of the field
so you can't really complain too much
since this was his first you know big
dance but uh for those of you who don't
know there was a lot of play after the
tournament bug house and silly chess
silly analysis between all the players
and based on what I heard from my homies
in Brugge aonian is the best Bug House
player mvl second and yer was third
that's what I heard so we had some
interesting bug house uh play at this
tournament afterwards um and the players
were playing blitzz and sort of acting
silly so when the tournament's over they
have more fun on the tennis courts mvl
lost a couple of matches but what are
you going to do he'll get better next
year so hopefully we'll have eight
players next year and that means the
commentators get paid more because more
work that's why I'm hoping for that and
uh what's that can we take a look at the
game where mvlb Carana in round seven
where mvlb Carana round seven why
somebody has a bad memory yeah terrible
terrible memory boy that the lower R you
are you sir what he's saying is yeah I
know what he's saying thanks for
translating from the Russian yeah right
so in any case uh those were the best
games from the tournament and this is
the best video you're ever going to see
I mean I mean there's the greatest
players there's the greatest
commentators and then there's me so
we'll see you next time here from the
chess club in Scholastic Center of St
Lou I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
out